Hey, look up, it's a bird.
No, it's a plane.
It's Facebook?
What's up guys?
I'm Andrew Dymburt for Buzz60.
Facebook is working on a fleet of drones, satellites and lasers.
Sorry Star Wars fans, they're not building a Death Star.
Facebook and its internet.org initiative...
...are looking to beam internet from the sky to every person in the world...
...because let's face it, one billion Facebook users just isn't enough.
Mark Zuckerberg announced the drone program in a Facebook post,...
...where he stressed the possibilities of worldwide internet availability.
The social media giant's new connectivity lab which includes NASA engineers...
...is trying to develop new technologies to make Internet for everyone a legit possibility.
This isn't the first time Zuckerberg and his team have expressed interest in drones.